If you want to hear the hidden meaning behind
these two CryptTV shorts, stick around to
the end of this video.
One of the best places to find high quality
short films right now is CryptTV.
So today, I'm going to be showing you some
of my favorite Crypt short films and a few
things you might have missed in each of them.
This video is sponsored by Crypt TV.
The first one I'm going to talk about is The
Mime.
If you haven't seen it, click or tap right
over here to watch it, and if you need a refresher,
it's about a woman's encounter with a creature
who mirrors her every move, and at the end
of the short, she finds that she's the one
being controlled by the movements of the mime.
But how did The Mime get this power over her?
My theory is that this tunnel has some kind
of power over those who pass through it.
She's able to go right to the edge of the
tunnel before it takes over her movements.
This little lip-balm tin seems to have something
to do with it.
It was the last item to have fallen out of
her bag and she ends up leaving it behind.
It's possible that she isn't able to leave
the tunnel without everything she came in
with -- and here's why I think that.
She spills her bag and picks up everything
but the lip-balm.
She tries to leave before finishing the job.
In this case, the job is picking up all of
her belongings.
Now rewind to the beginning of the short,
before Before Abigail enters the tunnel.
She's on the phone with a co-worker.
It's tough to hear her over the traffic, so
I'll turn on the subtitles.
"I was supposed to have it by five.
So now I'm gonna have to wait until Monday.
Okay, and it will be on my desk.
At nine."
One of her workers couldn't get the job done,
and thus, wasn't allowed to leave -- had to
work overtime.
I think that this idea leads into the meaning
of the short as well.
At the beginning Abigail is in a position
of power, controlling the movements of The
Mime, but when The Mime outsmarts her, he's
promoted to the higher position of power,
and now she has to follow his orders and she
pays the price for it.
So the whole thing is an allegory for the
unrelenting abuse of the corporate ladder.
The next short is a SciFi-Horror called Tethers,
in which a woman searching for her friends
in the midst of an alien invasion, receives
a warning from a dying stranger.
At the beginning she calls out the names of
her two friends.
"David?
Lynn?"
Hearing those names in succession makes me
think of psychological horror director David
Lynch, and it could also be an allusion to
the mind bending twist that's about to happen.
The guy she encounters gives a series of warnings
that all turn out to be to be true.
They're in the trees.
They send out things that get in your head.
Things that make you not yourself.
Don't trust anyone.
That last one plays with the idea of perspective.
Usually movies are told from the protagonist's'
perspective, so when Sarah runs into David
and Lynn, we expect the twist to be that they
are the ones taken over by the aliens, not
the character we've been following this whole
time.
And that's when we find out why the film is
called Tether, because they aliens have attached
themselves to the main character.
Both David and the stranger that we see at
the beginning drop their wallets when being
possessed by the creatures, which is symbolic
of losing your identity when an outside force
takes control.
The next short is called Terra, and it follows
a woman who moves to the desert, where she's
terrorized by her creepy nephew and a higher
being known as Terra.
Terra is an Italian word meaning land or earth,
and the being in this film takes on a violent
mother nature kind of role and uses her power
to protect her domain.
The opening shot shows this white flower being
turning red, almost as if it's being painted
with blood, and drawing a comparison of the
pollution of the earth to the gore of a human
being killed, which is a comparison we continue
to see throughout the movie as Terra gives
the enemies of the environment a taste of
their own medicine.
I also interpreted this water droplet to be
a teardrop shed by Mother Nature.
So we have two opposite characters in this
film.
Rachel, who is wasting water by running her
sprinkler in the day, running the washing
machine with only one item, leaving the faucet
running and that's not even half of the water
she's wasting during this movie.
All of this is amplified by the fact that
she just moved to the desert where water is
a lot harder to come by.
We know she just moved because she tells her
sister on the phone that land is stupid cheap
here, and she still has boxes to unpack.
She represents the European settlers in America
who moved out, took over the land and continue
to destroy the environment.
Then there's her nephew, who is not at all
wasteful.
When we first see him he's hitting spoons
against a vase like a native tribesman.
He represents the Native Americans who respect
the environment and who were negatively affected
by the industrialization of America.
He can be seen shutting off the running water
and the only time he uses water is to drink
it.
When Rachel is discussing with her sister
about letting Noah possibly stay another day,
she mentions her great maternal instincts.
However, we find that not to really be true.
She has no idea how to interact with the kid
and he creeps her out.
"Weird kid."
But I did find it interesting that she chose
the term "maternal instincts", almost a reference
to Mother Nature, which she also does not
fare well with.
Earlier I talked about the white flower being
stained with a red, blood-like substance to
represent Rachel "murdering" the environment.
We see this happen to the flowers around the
house as well as she continues to waste more
water.
One of the parallels I mentioned is on Rachel
herself.
Everything she wears before her death is white,
but in the scene where she pushes Terra over
the edge to take her life, she removes the
white bathrobe to reveal a crimson colored
bathing suit.
After her death the water leaving her body
turns to blood, which soaks back into the
flowers.
Noah recites the line, "from ashes to ashes,"
a biblical text referencing how our bodies
return to the earth after death.
I also find it interesting how Terra attacks
Rachel by using her own blows to the environment
against her.
For example, she first boils Rachels wine,
just as Rachel boiled the water for the coffee
the never even made.
Then in the hot tub, Terra takes back all
the wasted water from Rachel's body, leaving
her gasping for a drink even though she's
surrounded by the water of the jacuzzi.
In direct contrast to this, is the nephew,
Noah, who is drinking water out of his own
cup, which by the way is green, just like
his wardrobe, and everyone knows green means
environmentally friendly, right?
RIGHT?!
At the end, Terra tells Noah that she will
only hurt him if he hurts her first, more
evidence for her being a Mother Nature type
of being.
And just as Terra took back the water out
of Rachel's body, the next victim is also
punished with the same tactic that he used
to hurt the environment, when Terra changes
forms into a fire monster to attack the guy
who started a wildfire in the desert by dropping
his cigarette.
CryptTV also uploads some animated horror
films from time to time, like this one, Happy
Meal Horror.
It's made my a studio called Dark Vessel who
often makes films where the characters are
all living beings that look like robots, so
if you're wondering why all the characters
are robots, that's just their style.
This video is packed with references to other
horror movies.
The name of the place is Hooper's Meat, which
is an homage to the late Tobe Hooper, the
director of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre, and
Happy Meal Horror ends up having a little
chainsaw massacre of its own.
There are also a lot of references to Stanley
Kubrick films as well, such as the main antagonist,
this robot, having the eye of HAL from 2001:
A Space Odyssey and the floor of the meat
plant having the same design as the carpet
in the Overlook Hotel from The Shining.
This shot also doubles as a reference to Insidious,
which often uses the imagery of a red door
at the end of a blue tinted hallway in the
Further.
That's all before we even get to the titles,
which use the same font as American Horror
Story.
One little tidbit I found amusing is as the
cow is running away, there is a row of hanging
human skeletons, which brings up plenty of
questions, like are they using human meat
in their meals as well?
Are there humans in this world?
Or is that what the humanoid robots looks
like on the inside?
There's also a section with some chickens
as well, and they look more like rubber chickens.
And just a couple of fun notes, the robot
has a name-tag which reads: "EaRL", but it
doesn't appear to be a "My name is" style
name-tag.
This is also one of the few Crypt shorts to
have an animated title sequence.
The last one I'm gonna look at today is called
Selfish.
In order to understand this short, keep in
mind that everything that happens relates
back to this opening scene.
"You know the other night when we were at
Steve's?
We were talking about online dating.
You know, just chilling, discussing Tinder.
And what does she say?
She said something like, "Beauty's all about
being comfortable in your own skin.
Oh my God, can you believe that?"
The film presents us with two characters with
a twisted sense of beauty, characters who
can't see value in anything without makeup
and filters.
The horror of this short film comes when the
artificial beauty that they are so obsessed
with goes too far far and turns them into
monsters, in this case: literally.
As they are mocking this other girl and applying
their filters, Phoebe's eyes tweak out into
something terrifying momentarily.
It's easy to miss, but it's a sign of everything
to come when the filters start to consume
them.
There's also this picture on the wall, which,
here I'm gonna turn up the contrast.
It's pretty creepy and it's a perfect example
of the girls' screwed perception of beauty.
Katie claims that one of the filters looks
like Lady Gaga, and starts singing the lyrics
to Bad Romance.
"I want your ugly, I want your disease."
Well... she botches the lyrics a little bit.
"Ooh la la.
Want your performance.
Mmm...
Hm...
Mmm, mmm.
hmmm."
Probably to avoid getting a copystrike from
Interscope Records... but I think Bad Romance
is an ironic song for this character, because
I'd interpret Bad Romance to be a song about
an ugly romance, as opposed to the typical
fairytale romance you might find in Hollywood
blockbusters and Top 40 music.
With lyrics like 'I want your horror; I want
your design .'Cause you're a criminal as long
as you're mine, Gaga is telling her lover
that he's not perfect, but she doesn't want
him any other way.
And there are other horror references in the
song like 'I want your Psycho, your Vertigo
shtick.
Want you in my Rear Window.
Baby you're sick.'
They're all references to famous horror films
directed by Alfred Hitchcock.
But I'm getting sidetracked here, this is
'Things You Missed In CryptTV Shorts', not
'Things You Missed In Lady Gaga Songs'.
The main point to take away, is that the girls
are being hypocritical by singing a song like
Bad Romance, yet relying on crutches like
the filters to try to change their appearance.
I mean look at this one, it completely covers
her face, I don't know why that's desirable.
And going too far with the filters, Katie
eventually turns into one of those monsters,
and that's where the music makes a change
to a song from the 1920s by an artist named
Asa Martin.
The name of the song is "She Ain't Built That
Way", and the lyrics talk about how the stereotypical
tendencies of a 1920s woman, one of the verses
details how some women are lying with their
appearance.
"With bustles and padding and heels that are
high,
And blending of color just to capture the
eye,
But the real from the sham you tell if you
try
Because there's lots of them built that way."
So the song is talking about the artificial
way women try to enhance their beauty before
Instagram filters were a thing: bustles to
give the appearance of wider hips, padding
the bra, wearing high heels and blending makeup.
And the singer claims that you can tell the
real from the fake, but lots of women try
to use this deception.
The message of this verse is exactly the message
of the short film, it was just made about
100 years earlier.
On Phoebe's dresser you can see all the beauty
products, and there are also a couple dolls
in the room as well.
Dolls are another item, like filters, that
are supposed to be cute, but sometimes are
overdone and end up looking pretty creepy.
There's a whole genre of creepy doll movies
predicated on this.
You'll also notice a couple mirrors, which
have the same use as the front facing smartphone
camera, it's all about self validation.
Katie eventually finds Pheobe in her room
and she's now become the full monster version
of the little glimpse we saw earlier.
They are both consumed by filtering themselves
into something they are not, and they both
end up looking horrifying.
Eh, eh.
There's nothing else I can say.
Because that's the end of this episode of
Things You Missed.
The way you blowin' up my phone won't make
me heart your comment, but feel free to go
down and let me know your favorite Crypt film
and any other Things You Missed that I didn't
mention in this video.
I also did a video recently on the CryptTV
web series Sunny Family Cult, so if you've
already seen the series, then click the video
on the left for 43 Things You Missed, or if
you haven't watched Seasons 1 and 2, tap the
playlist on the right to do so.
And remember, it doesn't matter if you love
Crypt, or capital C.R.Y.P.T.
Just put your paws up and subscribe to CryptTV.
Cause you were born this way baby.
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.